now let's talk about the spark that led
to world war one and I want to emphasize
that this is really just the spark that
you can't really say that World War one
was caused by what we're seeing in this
video we already talked about the
Alliance system we already talked about
the militarization of most of Europe
especially Germany and Great Britain a
lot of these folks were frankly very
much primed for war and some would argue
even desired war for a whole set of
reasons Imperial reasons to keep their
opponents in check and to some degree or
to a large degree what we're talking
about was really just what allowed all
of these actors to act on what they had
been mobilizing for so there's a little
bit of background right over here and
we've already seen it before this is the
austro-hungarian Empire and you see it's
a combination of a bunch of ethnicities
and in 1908 in 1908 it formally it
formally annexes Bosnia and Herzegovina
so let me write that down that this is
an important point so 1908 you have
Austria Austria or Australia Hungary
annexes annexes Bosnia Herzegovina
Bosnia hurts hurts Bosnia and
Herzegovina I'll just write it like that
for now now we've already talked about
the ethnic connections between the
various people who speak serbo-croatian
especially between Serbians so you
already had with the kind of the the
fall or the the steady dissolution of
the Ottoman Empire you have a Serbian
Republic form right over here they have
the same language and religion and
considered themselves the same people as
a significant fraction of the folks
living in Bosnia and Herzegovina about a
third of the population in this country
are Serbian and Eastern Orthodox and
then of course the rest of the dominant
religion here or not the dominant I
would say the close to half of the
people were Bosniaks or Muslims you also
had a significant Co Asian population
but all of them had the same linguistic
tie so you can imagine there was a lot
of desire to unify this and frankly a
lot of anger at austria-hungary for kind
of splitting them apart and taking
/ or kind of ruling over the people who
are so close to them had ethnic and
religious ties and so the Serbian
government at the time there were
elements in it that were did not like
this that we're trying to trying to get
elements especially Serbians in Bosnia
Herzegovina to essentially rise up to
allow them to liberate themselves from
austria-hungary and one of them in
particular was gov reloj Princip Gavrilo
Princip and this is a quote from him
well later on after he had been arrested
and it will see why he got arrested in a
second and he says I am a Yugoslavian
list aiming for the unification of all
you don't you go Slavs and I do not care
what form of state but it must be free
from Austria so with up to this point
even though you had these linguistic and
ethnic connections and obviously you
have some religious differences but this
linguistic connection amongst the people
these southern Slavic States it had not
been unified before and when he's
talking about Yugoslavia Yugoslavia he's
talking about the southern Slavic states
he wants to form them in to one nation
and so on June 28th this is one of those
super famous dates in history On June 20
let me just say this is in nineteen so
all of what I'm going to describe now
all happens in 1914 and to some degree
the rapidity which is with that with
which it happens kind of speaks to the
fact of how primed Europe was for war so
1914 June 28th
you have the Archduke Franz Ferdinand
and his wife Sophie visit Sarajevo so
this is Sarajevo right here in Bosnia
right about right about there on this
map as well and Archduke Franz Ferdinand
he's the nephew of Franz Joseph the
current I guess you could call him the
Emperor or the ruler of austria-hungary
and he is the heir to the throne he is
the heir he is the heir to the throne so
you can imagine gov reloj Princip and
his co-conspirators were eager to do
something here and in particular they
planned to assassinate Archduke Franz
Ferdinand and actually the the details
and I'll maybe make a future video and
at the details of the assassination are
fascinating they essentially failed they
botched the assassination Gavrilo and
his co-conspirators and then later in
the day gov reloj Princip was just
hanging out he's essentially given up he
was eating a sandwich at a cafe and
because of a mistake made by those by
the folks planning Archduke Franz
Ferdinand and his wife's route Gavrilo
Princip saw his car coming and then when
they realized they had made the mistake
in the route they started backing up the
engine stalled and then Gavrilo Princip
essentially just walked put his sandwich
down walked up to the car and shot Franz
Ferdinand and his wife and assassinated
them so this is essentially what most
people point to as the spark that
triggered World War one and the reason
why that is is that immediately already
the austro-hungarian Empire they were
they were kind of peeved at all of this
unrest that the Serbians were causing
the Serbian nationalists had tried to
break up but to try to separate the
southern Slavic States from
austria-hungary now they've killed the
heir to the throne and so you
essentially have an ultimatum given by
Austria to Serbia to say look unless you
completely renounce all of this and have
100% guilt we you know we we we're gonna
we're going to take some action and
actually Serbia was not keen Serbia was
not keen to get into a war with a major
power in Europe and so that for the most
part they were like oh well you know
we're gonna look into this and and all
the rest it didn't they did they weren't
really kind of kind of beating the drum
beats but austria-hungary was eager to
kind of say hey look we can we can we
can deal with these characters right
over here and so austria-hungary did not
find how Serbia
Serbia's acceptance of guilt acceptable
and so in July 28th or July 28th let me
write this is his assassination
assassination of Franz Ferdinand Franz
Ferdinand and his wife Sofia and/or
Sophie and Sophie so on July 28th
Austria austria-hungary the
austro-hungarian Empire is not happy
with
essentially Serbia's apology or
acceptance of guilt or whatever you want
to call it and so they declare war on
Serbia declare war on Serbia and up to
this point they're like okay look we
Serbia is a relatively small state they
are very closely aligned with the
Russian Empire but the the Austrians at
this point said well you know the
Ospital Russians aren't going to try to
get into war with us over this we have
you know a reason to disagree with
what's going on they exercised bad
judgment there because the Russians were
very closely aligned were very closely
aligned with the Serbians they obviously
had a lot of roots they wanted to
maintain their influence in the region
and so you start to have a mobilization
of Russian troops so Russia begins to
mobilize mobilize so Russia Russia
mobilizes to help defend to help defend
Serbian this was actually a very fairly
slow process but now we have to go back
to the alliances that we talked about
several videos ago you have to remember
the dual alliance Treaty of 1879 Germany
and austria-hungary to protect each
other if Russia attacks and actually
even if Russia mobilizes and this is
kind of a legal this is kind of a legal
justification for why now Germany would
say oh I have to go protect our my Ally
austria-hungary but you have to remember
Germany had been militarizing for the
last several decades it had been
building a navy that could kind of hold
its own against the British it was to
some degree eager for war and so and so
very quickly and the rapidity with this
has happened shows how eager Germany was
for war at this point so literally
literally three days later August August
the first Germany declares war on Russia
Germany declares war on Russia and now
we have to go back to the alliances we
have the Franco Russian military
convention that says military assistance
both ways in the event of an attack now
Germany is aware of this and so Germany
says look why do we have to wait for
France
fully mobilized let's also because
France is gonna try to get into a war
and we're right in the middle between
the two so Germany two days later in
August 3rd
August 3rd declares so Germany declares
war war on France now at this point
Germany does not really want to get into
a war with the British Empire the
British Empire has a very powerful Navy
it's kind of the the other extremely
strong power but Germany is kind of
aware of this of the treaty this this
Treaty of London in 1839 this
seventy-five-year-old treaty and it
actually has contact with the British
and says look as we go if we attack
France we're probably going to go
through Belgium that's the Pfister the
fastest and easiest to route through
France you know you don't really take
this this this Treaty of London the
seventy-five-year-old treaty seriously
this fact that you're gonna have to
protect Belgium and the British who you
could argue also had a very strong
military footing said no we we do take
that thing very seriously so Germany it
very quickly moves into Belgium in order
to attack France and that gave that gave
the British Empire gave the British the
legal justification to then declare war
on Germany so let's see August 4th
August 4th Germany Germany invades so
the Germans were quick to action I mean
between the declaration of war on Serbia
and July 28 we're talking about six days
later Germany has invaded Belgium so
they were ready for this Germany invades
Belgium and then this gives the
justification for the British to declare
war on Germany so this leads to the
British declaring war war on Germany and
essentially world war 1 was now well
underway